it was the spring of 1948 in the world's
top physicists converge for a conference
in the Pocono Mountains included among
them was the brilliant Bongo playing
physicist Richard Fineman
one of the biggest problems in physics
was describing quantum interactions in a
way that's consistent with Einstein's
special relativity the possibilities and
potential problems seemed endless
Fineman presented a simple diagrammatic
scheme for keeping track of and
calculating the particle interactions
that's it these powerful tools in
physics became known as binding diagrams
[Music]
after World War 2 physicists wanted to
further develop the theory that
explained electromagnetism why like
particles repel each other and opposite
charges attract this theory called
quantum electrodynamics or QED attempted
to calculate the probabilities of all
possible outcomes of particle
interactions but there were two
seemingly insurmountable problems first
writing down the equations meant keeping
track of all possible particle
interactions including virtual ones a
grueling hopeless exercise for even the
most organized impatient physicists
second when quantifying the scattering
amplitudes the probability for how
particles come together dispersed or
transformed into other particles the
calculations break down producing
infinite values fineman's 1948 diagram
was a simple visual way to account for
and ultimately quantify all the
interactions think of this Fineman
diagram it's a story of a particle
interaction in space and time the
straight lines are particles of matter
like electrons and the wavy lines are
particles that convey forces like
photons in this simple interaction two
electrons scatter let's rotate this
diagram now the arrows are pointing the
opposite way and represent positrons or
anti electrons moving and exchanging a
photon each section of the diagram
corresponds to part of a QED equation
the stories of these scatterings begin
at the in and out states of the
interaction across those points energy
momentum and charge should be conserved
things get a little weird in the middle
since these intermediate virtual
particles can disappear and even go back
in time this means that any number of
bizarre interactions could happen in
this space there are infinitely many
possibilities for how a particle
interaction can occur but Fineman
diagrams allows you to chop off the
possibilities and calculate the result
at whatever level of precision you want
when Fineman first introduced his
diagrams his peers remained perplexed by
how to use them in their own work fellow
physicist Freeman Dyson translated the
diagrams into mathematics that
researchers could understand and work
with he also showed how infinities could
be converted into finite values through
renormalization soon the diagrams were
everywhere transforming modern
theoretical physics but after a time
their limitations became increasingly
evident when it comes to collisions of
subatomic particles like quarks and
gluons thousands of diagrams are needed
to calculate the relatively simple
scattering amplitude some physicists are
now working on a geometric approach for
scattering amplitudes called the
amplitude he drawn it all started at
that 1948 conference in the Poconos
Fineman diagrams helps unlock the
underlying physics of our universe on
the smallest scale
[Music]
you
[Music]